France 24 et RFI présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
sur France 24 et Radio France
Internationale bienvenue pour ici
l'Europe en cette semaine anniversaire
puisque nous avons célébré le 9 mai la
Journée de l'Europe et nous allons nous
pencher sur les attentes et
revendications de 450 millions
d'Européens pour en parler nous avons le
plaisir de recevoir aujourd'hui le
défenseur des droits de l'homme et des
travailleurs d'ailleurs il s'agit du
tout nouveau président du Comité
économique et social européen un organe
consultatif qui représente la société
civile pour les 27 Oliver que bonjour
merci d'être avec nous ici à Paris vous
avez été l'une des figures de la
Confédération autrichienne des syndicats
très forts partisan d'ailleurs d'un
dialogue social institutionnalisé j'ai
envie de vous demander évidemment
comment vous juger l'état moral et
social des Européens en votre début de
mandat de mandat de 2 ans et demi
c'est-à-dire en fait post pandémie et
avec une guerre en Ukraine à nos portes
voilà l'état de moral et social je pense
les citoyens européens
[Musique]
connaissent maintenant les crises les
crises multiples on a commencé avec la
crise financière on avait la pandémie et
maintenant on a la guerre de la Russie
contre l'Ukraine et je pense assez
vraiment un stress test pour l'Europe on
voit que les gens les gens encore
en confiance en Europe mais en même
temps bien sûr il voit que le problème
de inflation des précarité de
compétitivité sont vraiment urgents et
je pense ça c'est une mélange dangereux
pour la paix la paix dans le dans les
sociétés dans la société civile mais au
même temps c'est vraiment une chance
pour l'Europe une chance pour l'Europe
de montrer que l'Europe et la solution
peut être la solution et la future et je
pense quelques mesures pendant la
pandémie par exemple
le programme
ont montré que l'Europe si l'Europe
prend la bonne décision ça peut être une
solution pour la future Bruxelles la
Belgique qui doit avancer sur la réforme
des retraites pour recevoir ces fameux
fonds européens du plan de relance la
France qui s'est mobilisée contre elle
la réforme des retraites avec un âge de
départ à 64 ans comment vous comprenez
ces mouvements sur les retraites voilà
on a les débats dont beaucoup est un
membre et pour moi c'est nécessaire il y
a pas une solution qui est bonne pour
tous les pays parce que les systèmes
sont très différents comme ça on peut
pas comparer seulement le l'âge de
retraite d'un pays avec un lâche de
retraite dans un autre pays pour moi
c'est important comme président des
sociétés civiles la dialogue civile mais
aussi la dialogue le dialogue social je
pense ça c'est vraiment clé pour tous
les solutions je sais que il y a des
disputes et s'il a les disputes c'est
normal que les gens sont aussi dans les
rues mais à la fin je pense la politique
peut pas perdre le dialogue avec les
acteurs social et économiques alors
c'est vrai que on est dans un dans une
période inflationniste un taux
d'inflation un peu en baisse quand même
ce mois-ci mais toujours à 7%, 95
millions d'Européens en situation
précaire alors comment vous voyez cette
situation économique évoluée chez les 27
quand j'ai dit au début c'est très
dangereux et 7% c'est c'est vrai pour
quelques pays mais dans les autres pays
on a aussi une inflation encore plus
haut et je pense et il faut prendre des
mesures
des mesures contre l'inflation et pour
soutenir les gens le citoyen nous dans
le séisme dans le Comité économique et
social européen on a pris on a proposé
de mesures très tôt déjà avant la guerre
contre l'Ukraine par exemple on a mis le
problème de pauvreté ou de cette
précarité énergétique dans le centre de
notre de nos avis et aussi maintenant on
a beaucoup de propositions comment on
peut adresser cette problème de
inflation alors 60% d'ailleurs des
Européens pensent qu'il faut augmenter
les dépenses sociales l'Europe sociale
ça n'était pas vraiment à l'agenda ce
ces six mois donc ce semestre de la
présidence suédoise mais vous avez
peut-être plus d'espoir que ce soit
repris par la future présidente
espagnole à partir de juillet un
gouvernement socialiste voulait faire
quoi en matière de robe sociale
on a bien travaillé avec la présidente
suédoise aussi je dois dire mais c'est
vrai le gouvernement espagnol
a coopérer déjà très tôt bien à l'avance
de leur président avec notre comité le
gouvernement espagnol a demandé une
autre comité pour un avis exploratoire
ça c'est le mot technique mais en fait
ils veulent lancer quelques initiatives
dans domaine social ensemble avec les
politiques par exemple de renforcer la
démocratie dont dans l'économie la
participation
information de travailleurs par exemple
ou si
améliorer la compétitivité de notre
industrie vous proposez un nouveau panel
citoyen autour des élections européennes
de juin 2024 et pourtant il y a déjà eu
une convention citoyenne qui s'appelait
donc la conférence sur le futur de
l'Europe entre 2021 et 2022 et elle a
accouché d'une souris est-ce que est-ce
que des propositions étaient reprises ça
c'est une bonne question notre comité a
joué une rôle très actif très active
dans cette conférence et si on voit les
recommandations les conclusions de cette
conférence peut voir que beaucoup
beaucoup avis et position du comité sont
en fait intégrés dans le recommandation
mais maintenant c'est vrai on voit que
seulement quelques recommandations sont
réalisées la directive sur le salaire
minimum au niveau européen ça c'est
aussi une demande mais si on regarde
comment reformer notre Union européenne
pour la future pour l'élargissement de
la faute sur ici je vois que les choses
bougent pas
parce que les traités sont trop seront
trop compliqués à changer
c'est compliqué mais est-ce qu'il y a
une alternative je pense pas la vaste
majorité du parlement et aussi en faveur
de reformer notre Union européenne et le
chancelier allemand ou la chose il a
aussi demandé il a dit l'Europe doit
être
doit agir géopolitiquement vous avez
d'ailleurs choisi de placer votre votre
président
au Comité économique et social européen
sous les mots d'ordre de défendre la
démocratie et de plaider pour l'Europe
alors une Europe a toujours mal aimée
même en cette semaine anniversaire de de
l'Europe justement en France l'idée de
placer un drapeau européen sur le
fronton des mairies fait polémiques ça
vous choque
ça me choque pas parce que je pense ça
c'est une symbole et je suis je suis en
faveur de drapeau européen parce que si
je voyage dans les pays candidates par
exemple là-bas je vois presque partout
le drapeau européen mais à la fin il
faut
être convaincu pas l'idée européen par
les actions concrètes et je pense ça
c'est ce qu'on doit faire comme européen
le Parlement le Conseil et le la
commission ils doivent proposer vraiment
le chemin pour le pour la future ça
c'est plus important que le la question
de drapeau surtout que les Ukrainiens se
battent un peu quand même sous ce
drapeau européen en défilé sous le
drapeau européen pour défendre leurs
droits
oui mais l'Ukraine c'est une bonne
exemple
la guerre en fait la guerre
rapproché la société civile en Ukraine
avec notre société civile avant on avait
des contacts mais maintenant nous sommes
vraiment à côté de la société civile de
l'Ukraine et juste hier j'avais une
délégation des employeurs de l'Ukraine
je peux voir il voit leurs futurs en
Europe et ils veulent aussi travailler
avec notre comité et ça c'est la raison
pourquoi je propose de impliquer et de
associer représentant des sociétés
civiles
de l'Ukraine de moldovie et aussi de
pays de balcons
occidentaux dont notre travail au Comité
économique et social européen on va
parler de ces questions d'élargissement
mais prenons d'abord la direction de
l'Espagne ou un projet d'installation
d'une télécabine dans les Pyrénées a
divisé pendant plusieurs semaines
habitant et politique le gouvernement
régional souhaitait financer cette
télécabine grâce à des fonds européens
les fameux fonds next generation destiné
à la relance économique verte
post-covite de quoi faire bondir les
défenseurs de la nature qui ont alerté
Bruxelles récit d'un projet morné par
Céline Schmitt et Armelle explosito
c'est dans le canal Royat un espace
préservé des Pyrénées que le
gouvernement d'Aragon souhaiterait
installer une télécabine de 4 km pour
uneir de station de ski un projet que
dénonce kikorrillent ornithologue
mais qu'est-ce qu'on a là un gypaète
barbu
la vallée est en partie reconnue comme
une zone de protection spéciale pour les
oiseaux en plus elle offre différents
écosystèmes essentiels en Europe si le
projet voyait le jour il pourrait
provoquer la disparition de nombreuses
espèces
la région souhaitait que cette
télécabine soit financée à hauteur de 26
millions d'euros dans le cadre du plan
de relance européen poste covid des
fonds baptisés next generation dont
l'objectif est de construire un futur
durable creuser Louise porte-parole
d'une plateforme écologiste y a vu un
paradoxe qu'il est allé dénoncer à
Bruxelles
pour nous ce projet ne remplit pas les
critères nécessaires pour percevoir les
fonds next generation
principalement parce qu'il ne respecte
pas un prérequis fondamental celui de ne
pas détruire l'environnement
de nombreuses habitants de la région ont
également exprimé leur mécontentements
ce jour-là ils étaient plus de 2000 la
manifester
dans deux ou trois ans avec le
changement climatique il n'y aura plus
de neige ici du coup une heure de piste
de ski avec un téléphérique ça n'a aucun
sens le projet est pour l'instant à
l'arrêt certains élus du territoire
auront renoncé à cet usage des fonds
européens selon les associations c'est
la mobilisation des citoyens et les
doutes de Bruxelles qui ont freiné les
ambitions de la région une réaction à ce
reportage parce que finalement tout est
tout est vert maintenant est-ce qu'on
n'est pas en train de verdir des fonds
qui qui ne sont pas du tout destinés à
des projets de transition écologique
bien sûr et je pense les clés que dans
le dans le plan de relance
la société civile les acteurs
le partenaire sociaux doivent doit être
impliqué plus fort que ça
projet oui aussi par les consultations
je pense et c'est important et ça c'est
aussi la position de notre comité depuis
longtemps depuis longtemps on avait une
résolution et on va insister que tous
les mesures doit être avec
l'implication de société civile vous
avez déclaré la démocratie en Europe et
menacée non seulement de l'extérieur
mais aussi de l'intérieur vous pensiez à
quoi en l'occurrence en parlant de cette
société civile soumise à une pression
croissante
c'est vrai pour nous pour notre comité
l'État de droit le droit de l'homme la
démocratie était toujours dans le centre
de notre politique on a un groupe très
fort sur le droit de l'homme et l'État
de droit et ces groupes étaient très
actifs et je veux même renforcer le rôle
de ce groupe parce que le plan de
relance ça sert à ça aussi ça a été un
instrument qui était conditionné
maintenant au droit de l'homme dans la
Hongrie par exemple de Victor Orban en
le 4 mai le Parlement a voté finalement
une réforme de la justice qui permettra
une plus grande indépendance sous la
pression de Bruxelles qui qui je l'ai
une partie des vins de 28 milliards de
des fonds européens destinés à ce pays
les lois c'est bien et leur application
c'est mieux peut-être voilà c'est ça et
comme ça j'ai dit l'application est
importante et on veut être aussi
impliqué dans cette processus et on va
certainement on va certainement donner
notre avis comme comité mais comme je la
démocratie à l'intérieur en Europe je
parle aussi de pays de candidates parce
qu'ils sont aussi l'Europe même s'ils
sont pas encore membres de notre Union
européenne mais je pense il doit on doit
les préparer préparer le plus tôt
possible pour les agissements même si
c'est seulement dans quelques années
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de réticences à
cette élargissement sachant que ces pays
par exemple on pense au balcon
occidentaux avec des fortes tensions
entre Kosovo et la Serbie ils sont dans
un état effectivement de tension larvée
mais aussi avec des problèmes de
corruption majeur et c'est ce qui
empêche finalement notre enthousiasme
vis-à-vis de cette
élargissement
je dirais pas enthousiasme mais on voit
que le soutien dont le pays le soutien
pour l'Europe et encore très haut très
haut et je pense assez une chance pour
nous c'est vrai il doit améliorer la
liberté de presse la lutte contre la
corruption je suis sur si on être une
perspective une perspective pour
atterrir l'Union européenne je pense ça
peut améliorer les choses aussi les
relations entre la Serbie et le Kosovo
oui puisque nous parlons de l'état de la
démocratie effectivement parlons aussi
de votre pays Oliver hop que l'Autriche
avec en vue des élections législatives
de 2024 une extrême droite touchez il y
a quatre ans par un gros scandale de
corruption et qui caracole en tête des
sondages avec une ligne très dure contre
le soutien à l'Ukraine contre les
migrants pourquoi les Autrichiens
sont-ils séduits vos compatriotes
voilà comme on a dit au début il y a une
grande incertitude aussi dans la
population dans la société autrichienne
sur la future le problème d'inflation
par exemple c'est grand et tout ça bien
sûr c'est c'est bien pour le pour le
force populiste et pour le force
l'extrême mais les élections sont
l'année prochaine et je suis je reste
optimiste que à la fin les forces
démocratiques les forces pro-européen
vont gagner parce que
l'Autriche est un pays important dans
dans l'Union européenne je suis
convaincu que l'Autriche doit être agir
pro-européen ça c'était toujours le
succès et c'était toujours en faveur de
l'Autriche de coopérer avec l'Union
européenne avec ses voisins et je pense
ça c'est le chemin pour le futur la
Turquie qui vote ce weekend pour
renouveler et son parlement et son
président et
avec une société civile qui peut-être
n'a pas toujours reçu un soutien
suffisant de l'Union européenne quel est
votre position là-dessus est-ce que
cette société civile ces oppositions
c'est les parfois les les bien sûr les
associations et les ONG ont été
suffisamment défendus et soutenus par
l'UE
de notre part certainement on avait
toujours un
contact et un dialogue très fort avec la
société civile en Turquie mais c'est
vrai dans le dernier année
les contacts étaient plutôt gelés et
vraiment je regrette ça et je j'espère
que j'espère que après les élections la
situation va s'améliorer parce que la
Turquie est un partenaire important pour
nous pour l'Europe pour l'Union
européenne mais aussi la société civile
en Turquie est très importante pour nous
et comme ça on va certainement essayer
de renforcer nos relations avec les
acteurs en Turquie avec le société
civile en Turquie merci Oliver hop que
d'avoir été notre invité aujourd'hui
vous restez bien sûr sur notre antenne
puisque nous allons rejoindre à
Strasbourg je vais rejoindre ma camarade
Marie brémo de public c'est là pour un
débat justement consacré au futur
relations entre Union européenne et
Turquie poste élection en Turquie à tout
de suite
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre depuis le
Parlement européen à Strasbourg premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle en
Turquie l'occasion pour ici l'Europe de
faire le point sur les relations
complexes entre ce pays candidat depuis
1999 et l'Union européenne depuis 20 ans
au pouvoir et septa hyperdogan a
fondamentalement changé le visage de son
pays il est devenu un partenaire
indispensable mais instable des
Européens entre bras de fer et chantage
un président turc qui a rallumé la fibre
nationaliste dans son pays d'ailleurs il
a obtenu 6 milliards d'euros de l'Union
européenne pour retenir sur son sol 4
millions de réfugiés qu'il menace
constamment de laisser partir et puis
les liaisons des risques et l'entretien
avec le président russe Vladimir Poutine
inquiète ses voisins les négociations
d'adhésion ont été gelées par la France
et l'Allemagne depuis 2007 en raison de
la répression contre les Kurdes et les
opposants politiques la campagne
présidentielle a semble-t-il montré une
soif de changement des Turcs s'il était
réélu pour 5 ans
kurde un pouvoir plus autoritaire qui
s'est exprimé à partir de des événements
de 2013 sous l'élèvement au sujet de
d'un parc qui se transforme en un
mouvement populaire contre Monsieur
Erdogan et son gouvernement et qu'il va
réprimer par différents moyens de
manière assez sévère et puis un ensemble
de recul donc une justice qui n'est plus
autonome à la différence des progrès
qu'on avait vu jusque là un exemple nous
venons de le voter au Parlement européen
la convention d'Istanbul contre les
violences faites aux femmes elle a été
votée à Istanbul avec
Erdogan Premier ministre en 2011 et elle
a été dénoncée environ 10 ans plus tard
et il n'en est plus du tout question
aujourd'hui un revirement qui crée de
nombreuses tensions vous l'avez rappelé
dans le domaine de la migration dans le
domaine militaire aussi puisqu'il y a
parfois des opérations en mer Égée entre
les bâtiments Grecs et les bâtiments
Turcs auxquels les forces de l'OTAN et
notamment les français participent pour
faire respecter nos eaux territoriales
espère l'élection selon vous d'un nouvel
interlocuteur à la tête de ce grand pays
est-ce que une une défaite d'Erwan est
souhaitée pour que nos relations
s'améliorent
écoutez ça c'est bien sûr la décision
pour les Turcs à prendre c'est la
décision à l'élection pour la Turquie et
pas pour l'Union européenne de toute
façon la tuile qui est un partenaire clé
et essentiel pour le repos notre
stabilité pour notre
énergie même dans ce contexte là et
aussi pour pour arrêter le flux
d'immigration illégale envers l'Europe
donc c'est très important de trouver la
moyenne de partenariat avec le leader de
la Turquie
qui soit ça dépendra de la saison des
dieux de turc monsieur une alternance à
l'issue des élections Turcs
changeraient-elles fondamentalement la
donne et les relations diplomatiques
avec Bruxelles moi j'y crois fermement
dans la mesure où la nouvelle coalition
présentée par le président actuel est
devenu très à droite très nationaliste
et très islamiste et beaucoup plus que
cela était et auparavant effectivement
2002 et 2007 approximativement il y a un
discours très pro-européen il y a des
actes entre 2007 et 2010 et au
ralentissement et à partir 2010 pas à
pas une autoritarisation du régime mais
là en l'occurrence pour ces élections de
la coalition montée est tellement à
droite et tellement antioxydantal en
européen que j'ai craint que si Monsieur
Ardon est réélu les relations avec
Bruxelles soient complètement et
l'opposition est beaucoup plus
progressiste beaucoup plus européenne en
tout cas tourner vers l'Europe
effectivement effectivement c'est
beaucoup plus horizontal en tout cas
beaucoup plus collégiale et dans
l'opposition dans cette coalition de six
parties d'opposition de six parties très
dissemblables il y a une large coalition
un certain nombre de partis politiques
et des moments politiques sont
pro-européens pro occidental pro
sécularis prolaïque etc donc de ce point
de vue on peut espérer on peut voir un
changement de politique d'Ankara à
l'égard de Bruxelles si on alternance
politique Fabienne Keller on entendre
que monsieur edwiggy se féliciter du
Grand accord qu'on a noué effectivement
avec réceptai par douane sur les
réfugiés c'est aussi un objet de
chantage régulier de la part de réceptai
père douane n'empêche que aussi par
ailleurs il bloque l'adhésion à l'OTAN
d'un autre pays comme la Suède alors que
même fait partie de l'OTAN et que sans
cesse et bien il fait jouer son véto oui
les relations sont tendues c'est un
rapport de force permanent on peut
rappeler que cet accord a été passé
entre l'Union et la Turquie juste après
la guerre en Syrie en pensant que
c'était plus raisonnable de maintenir
les populations pas trop loin
géographiquement de leur pays d'origine
finalement la guerre enfin le régime
syrien est resté aux mains de Bachar
el-Assad d'une part mais avec beaucoup
de guerres fratricides à l'intérieur du
pays donc le retour des populations
réfugiées n'est pas envisageable pour
l'instant donc une renégociation de cet
accord de ces conditions et souhaitable
loin
menaces hybride c'est-à-dire des de ces
push il essaye de laisser faire alors
est-ce qu'il les pousse ou est-ce qu'il
les laisse passer en tout cas il
n'assure pas toujours les conditions
d'accueil qui ont été contractées avec
l'Union européenne pour que les migrants
puissent vivre correctement en Turquie
sachant que il y a des Syriens nombreux
qui sont accueillis dans l'Union
européenne depuis les ces dernières
années donc on voit que il faudrait
changer la nature de nos relations pour
qu'on puisse en parler ce sujet n'est
pas simple c'est la réponse aussi vous
commencez à le dire la défense aussi
c'est un sujet très sensible
pas la Suède l'as pas sinon la Suède qui
à qui on reproche finalement qui
Ardouane reproche finalement de de
laisser vivre sur son sol des opposants
et bien sûr nous avons besoin de clarté
au moment où la Russie a déclenché
Vladimir Poutine a déclenché la guerre
en Ukraine la Turquie fait partie de le
temps vous venez de le rappeler mais là
des attitudes parfois hégémonique
concernant notamment ces territoires
maritimes mais aussi ces frontières
géographiques donc il est important de
pouvoir avoir un dialogue plus apaisé et
respectueux et avec ce pays qui est
quand même important dans l'autre et
vous parlez de besoin de Claire clarté
mais la Hongrie aussi un bloc là-dessus
de la Suède à l'OTAN votre pays aussi
est accusé d'entretenir des relations de
proximité avec Moscou pourquoi le
président erdouan finalement peut-être
reste votre candidat favori malgré les
critiques nombreuses à l'encontre de son
régime écoutez nous pouvons critiquer
tout le monde c'est ça que nous voulons
faire mais moi je ne partage pas cette
approche cette attitude de donner des
leçons à tout le monde concernant
comment il faut créer une démocratie
comment il faut faire des choses il faut
respecter les autres et par exemple la
Hongrie nous nous avons construit un
très bon relation avec président Erdogan
et la Turquie et ça est basé sur la
respect mutuel et sur une compréhension
que nous avons des intérêts nous
Européens aussi et c'est pour être
autonome
entre la Turquie et l'Union européenne
par exemple la stabilité
géopolitique dans cette région là par
exemple approvisionnement de l'énergie
en utilisant le cœur qui Stream qui est
à la seule gazoduc pour l'instant
Est-Ouest qui fonctionne sans problème
et sans danger et salit nous à Azel
Bojan toute l'Europe centrale si on va
diversifier notre source d'énergie qui
est nécessaire
en ce moment-là l'azer bonjour et le
tour qui sont les play ou ça donc il
faut il faut boire tousser tous ces
points de vue pour construire un
partenariat support le mot ici à
Strasbourg ou à Bruxelles nous pouvons
passer chaque semaine une condamnation
de la Turquie faire des exigences en
expliquant qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
mais c'est mieux mais c'est mieux pour
l'autonomie politique européenne de de
construire un partenariat qui accepte
les différences de temps en temps mais
monsieur vous êtes le seul à avoir cette
attitude les autres essaient de
travailler en européen c'est-à-dire tous
ensemble et la Hongrie se distingue au
Conseil européen par exemple en
appliquant pas les sanctions à l'égard
de la Russie qui est aujourd'hui qui a
agressé un pays amis l'Ukraine vous avez
la même ambiguïté vous portez le même
ambiguïté pour chaque sanction nous
avons nous avons les appliquez pas je
rappelle que vous avez vacciné vous avez
été les seuls à accepter le vaccin russe
le Spoutnik qui n'était pas chinois
parce que c'est
l'intérêt stratégie affaibli toute
l'Union européenne c'est d'ailleurs pour
cela que vous l'appliquez énormément de
division en Europe sur le cas sur le cas
de en Turquie pas seulement de la
Turquie j'ai l'impression
de la Turquie et ce gel donc progresser
vers l'Union européenne elle l'a fait
mais est-ce que tout d'un coup les
européens se sont dit ah bah mince c'est
un pays qui a à peine 5% de son
territoire en Europe c'est un pays qui a
85 millions de personnes c'est plus que
l'Allemagne donc ça va bouleverser notre
équilibre géopolitique ils se sont
rendus compte qu'ils avaient fait une
bêtise qu'est-ce qui s'est passé déjà
entre autres bien sûr mais déjà la
géographie n'est pas tout à fait un
acteur dans la mesure où l'Europe se
termine s'arrête là où on dit qu'elle
s'arrête le Conseil de l'Europe est à
côté dans le bâtiment à côté et le pays
la Turquie est un des pays quasiment
fondateurs du Conseil de l'Europe
deuxièmement effectivement il y a eu une
crise de l'Union européenne également
l'approche à l'égard de la Turquie a
changé entre dans tout ce débat là entre
une Europe fédérale dont d'autres
personnes n'en parle d'ailleurs et donc
approfondissement et allergissement il y
a eu cette crainte de l'Europe d'aller
au-delà du Bosphore vers le
Proche-Orient ceci étant dit il y a des
pays qui ont pu faire partie de l'Union
européenne qui sont déjà dans cette
région là je pense à la Bulgarie je
pense à Chypre par exemple en 2004 qui a
fait partie de l'Union européenne donc
de ce point de vue effectivement il y a
une double standard à mon avis l'Europe
a raté la coche ça aurait été évidemment
on fait pas l'histoire avec des sites
mais si la Turquie avait fait partie de
l'Union européenne en 2004 par exemple
dans cette vague dans le logement nous
n'en serions pas l'agence puis certain
alors si les Turcs choisissent un leader
moins autoritaire est-ce qu'il faudra
dégeler une négociation d'adhésion
Fabienne Keller bien sûr ce sera 8
francs et massif pour vous ce sera remis
sur la table bien sûr c'est un grand
pays s'il veut évoluer vers la
démocratie vers le respect de l'État de
l'Union européenne est prête à
accueillir ce pays qui avec ses 85
millions d'habitants alors que on vient
de voir que entre guillemets certains
avaient reconnu avoir fait une bêtise ou
une erreur en ouvrant c'est négociations
nous verrons mais ce serait un pas
considérable pour la Grande Europe celle
du Conseil de l'Europe que d'avoir un
pays qui veut s'orienter à nouveau vers
le respect de l'État de droit vers les
principes de la démocratie et la
relation doit changer avec l'Union
européenne par rapport à celle qui est
aujourd'hui très tendue sous le régime
de Monsieur Erdogan mais c'est la
question aussi du concept de communauté
politique européenne qui sera discuté le
mois prochain en Moldavie après un
sommet du Conseil de l'Europe dans
quelques jours le 16 et 17 mai arrêt
kjavik la Turquie sera partie prenante
et c'est intéressant qui est des lieux
dont elle fait partie pour la
négociation pour dessiner aussi de
nouvelles missions pour le Conseil de
l'Europe donc tout ça bouge dans quelles
conditions exactement on ne sait alors
mélodie le fidèles par exemple monsieur
monsieur itvi rappelle sans cesse les
racines chrétiennes de l'Union
européenne la Turquie qui est déjà à 10
un pays très laïque après la période
erdoine et on a parlé d'un islamisme
modéré modéré parce que finalement ces
réflexes là ils sont moins forts est-ce
que ça vous pose problème dans une
perspective d'adhésion pas du tout là
Hongrie était sous l'Occupation automne
pendant 150 ans donc nous connaissons
cette expérience mais si une coopération
est basée sur la respect mutuel il
acceptation de l'autre dans l'autre
musulman pas de problème
on peut coopérer et je veux déposer la
question à madame Claire si vous me
permettez vous étiez à l'UMP pendant
beaucoup des années maintenant vous vous
trouvez dans la partie de votre
président Macron le président Macron a
parlé à propos de la stratégie autonome
européenne une vision que nous
partageons en fait la Hongrie nous
pensons c'est important est-ce que vous
êtes pro ou contre la vision de Turquie
à l'Union européenne est-ce que vous
pensez que ça nous aiderait dans notre
stratégie géopolitique dans dans nous
faire membre du parti de Monsieur Orban
et vous avez l'habitude de ne pas
s'établir les journalistes poser les
questions vous avez l'habitude d'imposer
vos points de vue c'est la technique de
Monsieur Orban
les médias qui a muselé les médias
hongrois comme vous le savez la dernière
radio libre à Émilie il y a 2 ans les
toutes les télés sont contrôlées par
votre pouvoir vous souhaitez étendre ce
concept rassemblement national
s'il vous plaît je viens de l'expliquer
c'est un pays avec lequel nous devons
approfondir le dialogue dans les
différentes instances européennes et
comme vous le savez le chapitre de la
vision les chapitres de l'addition ne
sont pas du tout satisfaits aujourd'hui
par la Turquie mais ce dossier est
ouvert et nous souhaitons que ce grand
pays progresse dans la voie de la
démocratie dans la voie de la démocratie
est-ce que vous y croyez vous à des
perspectives à une perspective à
l'avenir de relance de de négociations
d'adhésion à la Turquie premièrement la
Turquie ne se limite pas à le jobtail
pardon c'est à dire que c'est un
président effectivement
c'est un président autocrate
effectivement qui a monté qui est
construit un régime à son image celle-ci
est vrai mais c'est un grand pays de
plus de 80 millions de populations avec
des institutions avec une histoire avec
des écoles des universitaires une
société civile et très forte et très
très dense les deux grandes villes qui
étaient aux mains de la cape donc Ankara
Istanbul la capitale la capitale
économique et culturelle Istanbul sont
au même de la peau de l'opposition
maintenant d'autres grandes villes
également donc de ce point de vue le
pouvoir régional et local et passer en
quelque sorte de l'opposition donc on
peut voir si l'opposition gagne les
élections présidentielles et
législatives en même temps n'oubliez pas
qu'il y a le premier tour c'est
européenne vous dites de la Turquie
c'est ça paraît évident la Turquie fait
partie de l'Europe sauf pas de l'Union
européenne il y a des chapitres qui sont
prêts il y a des chapitres qui sont où
il y a eu des progrès d'autres non bien
entendu qui ont été bloqués et bien
nouveau régime une alternance peut
permettre la réouverture de négociation
et merci merci à tous les trois d'avoir
débattu autour de la Turquie nous
suivrons bien sûr le résultat du premier
tour du second tour aussi à venir sur
nos antennes à très bientôt à tous
[Musique]